we still use this word today liberalism
right yeah in some quarters it's a dirty
word as a matter of fact a lot of people
who two generations ago and be perfectly
happy to be discussed as political
liberals now call themselves
progressives because they wanted to
associate themselves from some of the
baggage of the term it has a specific
meaning in religion as well and your
book talks about it in terms of a few
traits so it talks about liberal
liberalism and implying a concern with
ethics rather than metaphysics that may
not be that easy to relate to even
though you've had your philosophical
perspectives class because what is
metaphysics but the physics is you know
speculation or doctrines about what's
ultimately real and so liberals are more
interested in well how do we fix society
or how do we take care of the neighbor
rather than worrying about abstruse
theological points there is a there's a
focus on this world rather than
supernatural there is an impatience with
rigid barriers separating groups of
people realms of thought or categories
of being there's a tendency to sort of
where those down to say those don't
matter so much there's a confidence in
the powers of the individual to discern
ultimate truth so think about any other
Quakers in the natural light that we
talked about last class session that
would be an example of this without
reliance sorry without reliance on
Revelation tradition or external
Authority and a predisposition to see
human nature is is fundamentally good
those are those are how liberalism tends
to play out in terms of religion and
where did this where do these ideas come
from I mean if you have somebody
mentioned original sin earlier if you
really stress original sin you're
probably not going to be a liberal
because original sin means we're all
screwed up we're all a bunch of
screwed-up people just like a couple
steps away from being terrible so that's
very different than you know sort of
broad sense that human beings are
fundamentally good you're all familiar
with the Renaissance all right the
Renaissance is a time they had a lot of
people who fit into this tradition look
back to is a particularly good time time
when things were on the rise the
Renaissance you know the term means what
read something right very good rebirth
and rebirth of what what do you remember
from your lit classes or history facts
towards ya so we associated with
painting and sculpture music to a
certain certain degree now those were
being driven by a rebirth in terms of
thought and they were going back to
leesburg ancient pre-christian thought
greco-roman block there's an increased
emphasis on scholarship they wanted to
go back to what they thought were the
pure sources of Western culture like
Plato or Aaron not aerosol they didn't
like him because the scholastics accused
Arizona epictetus some of the people you
may have studied in your philosophy
classes they also tend to be very very
critical of tradition we often associate
this with any humanism humanism versus
tradition so be a humanist meant to
focus on human nature and what we could
know about and in the human experience
it's very this worldly isn't it and you
know you know a number of different
who fit in with that you think you know
you mentioned the arts so you think of
Michelangelo or Leonardo DaVinci your
book talks about volim who by the way we
have a person who knows quite a bit
about in the philosophy department who's
about a specialist in Renaissance
philosophy and the Renaissance leads to
rediscovery a lot of culture that had
then been left behind now let's good
after the Renaissance really you know in
many respects these go hand in hand is
the Reformation right and they're going
to influence each other and in the
Reformation you have people like Martin
Luther and John Calvin John Calvin is
extremely well educated and you also
have people like your book mentions
Erasmus who is a humanist Erasmus was
actually a guy who corresponded with
Lutheran tried to argue Luther out of
his position Erasmus remained a Catholic
but he was intensely critical of some of
the things that we're going out in a
Catholic Church almost as critical as
Luke it was now why you know why would
he do that why why didn't you just take
a side and say you know Luther you've
gone too far everything capital A okay
whatever the Pope wants is what we need
to do well because he's devoted to these
ideals and so within the Catholic Church
there were there were critics as well
another person who you know about
Galileo what's he famous for
decided to being persecuted that's why I
think he's famous for proving Aristotle
was wrong about some things and
endorsing the Copernican view of the
cosmos and then of course he gets he
gets put under house arrest so he's sort
of a patron saint of this entire
movement and there's a lot to be said
one side or another you know without
fries male how much Galileo himself
brought about that situation but I I'll
skip over that they talk about another
guy Francis Bacon who writes the mighty
may know him from the idols of a cave
one of his main essays but he writes a
new new logic to try to help think out
all these sort of problems it also talks
about Sir Vettes sir Vettes is a
particularly unfortunate guy he's a
freethinker and he is being chased by
the Catholic Inquisition so where does a
free thinker go to go to the Protestants
they burn him at the stake so he
literally goes out of the frying pan
into the fire but he's looking of it why
does he burned at the stake he looked at
as being a heretic the Reformation
didn't necessarily bring about increased
freedom of thought and Calvin's Geneva
you know you could get yourself in a lot
of trouble so this is what's going on
for a while and then something new comes
about that has its roots in these and
you're probably all familiar with this
as well enlightenment if you're if
you're thinking in religious terms you
may associate enlightenment with Eastern
religions but there's actually a period
of time at the quality enlightenment and
it roughly you know think about the 18th
century primarily although it's got 17th
century roots and during the
Enlightenment you have all these
intellectuals it's an intellectual and
to some degree social and political
movement a lot of criticism of existing
culture 40 society and the view that
human beings are human reason cannot
understand and solve all of our problems
you know for example more or family or
disease or unhappiness among human
beings the Enlightenment was a period of
optimism where they thought you know you
can just think things through get rid of
all the things that are keeping you from
thinking it through we could fix
everything didn't turn out that way in a
lot of cases you'll think about the
history of the French Revolution which
is very much a enlightenment development
the Revolution was good in park has it
got rid of the king and a lot of the
nobles but how did it get rid of them I
remember then yeah eventually the
guillotine and then after you're done
with the the nobles who gets guillotine
lot of the very people who belong to the
revolution of the first place you have a
terror and pretty soon you have you know
somebody like Napoleon coming about and
then you have decades of intense warfare
taking place you want it as always as
you know it it's a fact is not always as
good as
as its promises but in promise the idea
is if we could just get rid of these
traditions these things that are holding
us back we would be able to have a sort
of new even a new paradisiacal state on
earth we could reconcile human beings to
each other if you think about the French
Revolution and its ideals equality all
right of all people everyone should be
equal sometimes religion would preach
inequality right freedom liberté
fraternity Brotherhood relatedness
everyone being you know together these
are very high heels and they thought
that the traditional religion was
interfering with that so some of the
Enlightenment thinkers that we could we
could look at would be people like Isaac
Newton and John Locke here in America
the ones that would be particularly
important with the guys like Benjamin
Franklin you know you probably
associated Benjamin Franklin we had a
few know the kind experiment and being
kind of a fat guy and I'm wearing
wearing on vast and maybe being a
printer and having the spectacles but he
was incredibly important not only to the
revolution the two American and he is he
wrote an autobiography felt like your
book points out it was really sort of a
secular version of John Bunyan's
Pilgrim's Progress which was one of the
best-selling books at that time and
Benjamin Franklin was a successful man
he's a self-made man and he attributes
his success to developing certain
virtues where is he eating these virtues
from Jesus and Socrates try to imitate
those two guys which more neither more
as a matter of fact that Jesus guy only
insofar as he is you know showing you an
ethical way of life then we have Thomas
Jefferson
another incredibly important figure
they're actually part of what's called
the American Enlightenment yeah what do
you associate Jefferson historically
easel yeah very good deism we'll talk
about just just a moment what else
here's a president so that that's it
gives you a lot of power what else and
you have a lot of slaves yeah he was
kind of uh you know all men are created
equal thing a little bit hypocritical on
that you know very descendants to
Jefferson from from some of those slaves
what else like the really prove it yeah
why John Locke slightly protection of
property yeah Jefferson has influenced
by it by lock and what documents is this
going into what key document the
Declaration the Declaration very good so
the Declaration of Independence you know
one of the founding documents of the
United States is penned by Jefferson
these P right is drawing unlock he's
changing things a bit property becomes
the pursuit of happiness the rhetoric
that Jefferson muses is coming out of
the Enlightenment and it's incredibly
influential he's also one of the people
who starts talking about the separation
of church and state in his letter to the
Danbury Baptists wall of separation
between church and state not in the
Declaration not in the Constitution it's
in a document that Jefferson rope as a
letter but it becomes part of our or
national consciousness Jefferson is like
you put it out a deus yeah deism is this
notion that
God is is a creator but a lot of the
things that the religious people are
teaching about God it is dead wrong God
starts the world and you can tell that
God started the world because he
implanted the moral law on human beings
and implanted order in things order and
strike then its hands off he doesn't do
miracles he not only doesn't work on
Sundays he doesn't work on any day he's
done all the work that he's going to do
and the goal then is for human beings to
orient themselves properly to God
through the use of reason not through
religion through reason alone thomas
paine by the way another important
american daya stand enlightenment figure
writes a book called the age of reason
which is explicitly giving an argument
in favor of days and along the lines of
Jefferson Jefferson like your book
points out came up with his own version
of the the Gospels where he literally
cut out every passage were some miracle
took place because the view was God
doesn't mess around with the laws of
nature doesn't do that sort of thing so
it's a very short book because in the
Gospels you know there's that there's an
awful lot of miracles taking place isn't
there you know the changing water into
wine healing people the loaves and the
fishes if you were to do that what would
be left of the Gospels what pieces of it
would he have maybe the travelogue Jesus
went here then he went there went up in
the mountains went in the desert got on
the boat what else that's not very
interesting don't nobody cares work
where he went just for its own sake what
else would you yeah take all the
miracles out all the all the
supernatural occurrences
what would be left in the story that
Jefferson would care about yeah parables
yeah now why would why would those still
be there what's the importance of the
parables they outline some sort of the
basic value each one yes that's exactly
right they set out a way of living and
an ordering of values along with that
would go some of the other sayings you
know like on the server on the Mount
beatitude is blessed are those who do
this that's saying you should live this
way that's the setting out kind of
ethics so the Jefferson Bible reduces
religion to to ethics it tries to get
rid of anything super dancer now how how
influential was this that's a good
question he asked how how much did this
catch on was this always kind of an
elite movement the answer to that is yes
it never became in a truly popular
movement your book talks about religious
people having to accommodate themselves
to this to some degree and oftentimes
they did it through through hybrid sort
of bringing together and lighten the
thought but also more traditional
religious a lot and one way in which
this happened was through what they're
calling the Scottish common sense
philosophy which we actually don't teach
much an intro philosophy classes anymore
it's not it doesn't have much around
much influence but it had a lot of
influence on early American thought in
part because there's the ethics thing
coming in they taught not only that you
know we learn things by experience by
reasoning but also by could sort of an
innate sense for what's right and wrong
we have a sense for the the moral that
allows us to to make responsible choices
the book also mentions one other things
which is another ISM which is worth
pointing out because it's going to turn
up again later on universalism
and they don't exist